[Musique]
animaux
le
[Musique]
après un rapide ici
dans cette fosse
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non pas deux
attendu
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
qu'est ce qu'un bon
[Musique]
dans le secteur
avec n'importe qui
[Musique]
c'était pas mal
soit vous voyez bien que c'est pas un
vêtement banal fait confiance ou pas non
je suis tout seul je suis tout seul mais
enfin j'ai tout seul
[Musique]
je connais ma fille elle a jamais été
aussi l'heureuse jeudi soir ait gelé pas
touché je suis fidèle taper chemin et
non je prêche pas très chaud à le taper
chose ça sécuriser la bombe on le
faisait que la plupart des hommes sont
fous ces mêmes soyez là pour lui dire
adieu à dieu pour ce qu'il verrait plus
jamais non on va se remettre ensemble on
est une famille
il faut parler à garance doré je lui
parlais pour mettre les points sur les i
rebonjour poster les tambours le conflit
et non ça c'est pas facile et plus
étroit qui est pas possible on fout pas
toute sa vie relais à cause d'un coup on
a compris qu est ce que vous n'avez pas
compris dans la phrase il ne faut plus
jamais revoir surtout le crime il n'a
pas déçu par un détective comme un chat
au fond du trou c'est un homme brisé
ceux qui pleurent tout le temps
[Musique]
voilà un pas pour bientôt un stand
inspections et des trucs que j'aimais
faire avec quelqu'un dont on ne prononce
plus le nom mais voilà aujourd'hui je
suis obligé de faire tout seul la cité
les noms tels pâté maison t'arrête pas
sinon on est mort moi ça va pas du tout
avec picchu
qu'est ce que vous faites un tour
nouveau quartier comme ça papa derrière
l'as cambérène d'angleterre
on l'avait jamais fait et que ça faisait
plaisir at on peut
[Musique]
pourquoi tu veux que je te dise on
n'arrive pas à couper le cordon voilà
c'est tout on n'est pas des machines bon
sens
j'ai acheté la place que j'ai sur ce
tournage je peux pas risquer de tout
perdre c'est impossible
comme il est quoi lui je vais pas vous
dire son nom il ya quelque chose que je
vous ai pas dit long couple avec la
réalisatrice du film
vous voyez d'où venait son tournage moi
j'arrive peut réfléchir j'arrive plus à
me projeter non c'est impossible ça
aux éditions castelli pionniers
audacieuse plus égoïste petite histoire
[Musique]
sencha
toi y'a des gens fêtent leur vie sont
très malheureux et il n'arrive jamais à
guérir du malheur a du coup ils sont
obligés de prendre plein de trucs pour
oublier qu'ils sont et qui quand il
reste de l'énergie la consacre
essentiellement à pourrir la vie des
autres tu apprennes à manipuler tamer
plus ça te servira pour plus tard parce
que tu sais tu cumules de choses avec
elle cette amère et les psys
mon supporte pas parler ça pourrait
arriver dans l'ailé tu poses et qui sont
vraiment étrange pour son argent
sam jazz
aujourd'hui les gens ils sont saturés
d'information ils ont plein plein de
raisons de ne pas lire donc en fait ça a
jamais été aussi illégitime qu
aujourd'hui peut-être de publier un
livre dont je dis pas ça pour te
décourager ce tract est peut-être parti
au plus mauvais moment quand tu m'as dit
à 10 ans que tu arrêtais que tu voulais
devenir si tu me dis que tu vas t'y
remettre que tu fais le vide au second
poteau et c'est super c'est super sauf
qu'on sait très bien que l'inspiration
toi comme moi ça n'existe pas et on sait
aussi que le travail sa sert a réuni
daniel simoni qui l'a qui va sortir un
livre là je crois sur leur affaire
d'hommes de meurtre par texto si une
meuf t'a envoyé des centaines de textos
un ami elle suicidaire jusqu'à ce qu'il
passe à l'acte
ça c'est un bolide de femmes
journal de bord les passagers sont
montés à bord en croyant sincèrement que
ce serait le plus beau voyage de leur
vie comme ils se trompaient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vraiment magnifique
nicolas baskin ce premier officiel du
barbara d'ougrée lance de m
mesdemoiselles villanueva
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant cette obscurité
fini par en tomber amoureux
un homme à la mer à bâbord monsieur
il ya une bagarre au moins deux
personnes sont entrées c'est flagrant
cette femme n'est pas tombé à l'eau
acquis sida
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle cherche à
quelque chose il ya un assassin sur ce
navire l'accès au reste du navire vous
ai strictement restreint annoncé un mois
plus tard risque gros à ce voyage car
l'ena
je vois que québec pas des yeux
[Musique]
ça peut arriver
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certains secrets sont encore plus
profond que l'océan
[Musique]